all right let me just share some really
fascinating news
about the olympics please a track star
at northern arizona university will get
to live his olympic dreams after all his
name
is luis rihalda he qualified for the
olympics earlier this summer to
represent guatemala
but he soon realized getting the tokyo
would be tough
that is because he's a daca recipient
part of an obama era policy that
protects immigrants who came to america
when they were kids now normally
daca recipients who leave the u.s are
not permitted to return
ralva spent the last several weeks
petitioning the u.s government and
yesterday he received word that he can
travel to tokyo he's got yeah what's
called
an advanced reentry document and he'll
now be able to leave the country
to compete 5 000 meter
yeah yes 30 seconds faster than the next
person
i know i know he also he also held
northern arizona to three
uh they they won three ncaa cross
country championships
in four years he's a big deal and you
know
i'm cheering team usa always but there's
been so much high drama
over many events did you all see the
diving competition yesterday
no oh my god great britain and china it
was a nail biter
it was a nail biter yeah and then of
course i've got i love this story
hindulin
uh diaz she's the philippines first
ever look at that first ever gold medal
in 100 years of trying i know these
these are the really wonderful stories
they really really are anthony it's
always disappointing to see
naomi osaka lose but then you see
stories like that there are other
stories
other stories like that 100 years
philippines have been trying to get to
the top spot and they finally
made it yeah isn't it pretty cool